during the mid-2000s the superhero genre
was finding a second win as the world of
special effects could bring more and
more characters to life in ways that
we've never seen before Spider-Man could
finally believably swing through the
cavernous streets of New York the Hulk
could transform before our very eyes and
the X-Men were squeaking every time they
moved because of the 40 cows worth of
leather wrapped around their mutant
bodies but one superhero fell into the
middle area between the comic book
reviewing Spider-Man and Hulk films and
the partially embarrassed by their
Source material but still pretty good
anyway X-Men and Blade movies
Daredevil I've always found this movie
an interesting Paradox because it's sort
of all over the place it wants to be
serious at times but it also seems to be
completely stupid and silly on purpose
it wants to do a respectful adaptation
of the source material in some ways but
also tramples on other parts of it for
some kind of cool factor that doesn't
really stick The Landing that
like that's not heaven
it's the first real attempt to capture
the street level World of Marvel
Superheroes Spider-Man's kind of street
level but he's also kind of Avengers
level
Daredevil's all about the Grim and
gritty underworld of Buzz saw glove
wearing criminals and stilt-based crime
and in Daredevil 2003's bombastic
attempt to bring The Man Without Fear to
the big screen they also spawn an even
weirder spin-off movie that I don't see
anyone talk about Daredevil seems to be
an easy punching bag for movie fans when
they're talking about how superhero
movies have a shaky start before the MCU
took off but I want to take a real look
at what does and doesn't work with this
one Through The Eyes of well the radar
sense of a big fan of the comics it's
based on was Daredevil 2003 really that
bad Elektra sure what but first a word
from our sponsor special thanks to
raycon for sponsoring this video raycon
is on a mission to prove that you
shouldn't have to pay an arm and a leg
for Quality sound and essential smart
Tech listening features it's a no BS
product you can get a pair and a spare
and still pay less than you would with
some of those other more big name Tech
Brands out there when I'm editing videos
I need crisp and clear sound to balance
audio and sometimes I just like to
listen to music while reading comics
normally I find earbuds cause me
discomfort but raycon earbuds use custom
gel tips for the perfect most
comfortable in-ear fit and have eight
hours of play time for everyday earbuds
I also love the easy use touch controls
that give three different sound profiles
for whatever you need if you want high
quality earbuds for a good price and an
easy way to help support my channel
click the link in the description or go
to buy raycon.com forward slash Godzilla
Mendoza to get 15 off your raycon
purchase now back to the video
Daredevil's plot focuses on the secretly
superpowered disabled lawyer Matt
Murdock as he attempts to battle the
criminal forces in Hell's Kitchen New
York by day through the legal system and
by night as a crazy ninja man dressed
like Satan we see his origin story where
his father was taken from him by Crime
Boss Hector Salamanca
I need to see you a boss
after he was splashed in the face by
tcri ooze that stuff is spaceship fuel
as an adult he finds romance with
Elektra the daughter of a billionaire
who is assassinated by the city's
Kingpin of crime and he has to clear his
name when he's framed for the Murder by
a Hitman known as Bullseye and the
extended director's Edition there's also
a lot of extra stuff about trying to
figure out who killed this call girl and
how it relates back to Kingpin and
weirdly it's not all that interesting or
relevant there's some halfway decent
attempts to adapt a few different
Daredevil storylines or at least remind
you of the source material
the angle's a little off on the side but
I see what you're trying to do there the
first shot of Daredevil himself is right
out of the Guardian devil covers though
even as a kid I was bothered by the
origin story omitting the character's
stick only because I saw him in the
Spider-Man crossover episode I remember
back then I just assumed he showed up
off screen at some point but it really
seems like they just ignored that
altogether a lot of this feels wrong
though because I feel like everyone in
this movie is kind of miscast except for
foggy Nelson and Kingpin John favreau's
made an acting career out of being the
tired of your sidekick to
superheroes it's funny that he's gotten
to share a scene with both Matt
Murdoch's and it's a shame that this
movie spends so much time up bullseye's
ass that we don't get enough Michael
Clark Duncan screen time as Wilson Fisk
he's got the perfect imposing Kingpin
figure without ridiculous shoulder pads
in his suit and lifts in his shoes I
wanted to know more about this version
of the character and how he totally
fought Spider-Man 2 one time but for the
length the director's cut he still
doesn't get enough time to really shine
which is a damn shame Ben Affleck has
gone on record that he hates this movie
and you can see his frustration a little
while he's performing in it you just
know he wishes it was better because
that's the kind of actor and director he
is talk to me about blindness and how he
moved and how he counted money and what
his house looked like and I thought that
was the most interesting thing about the
movie frankly a lot of the other stuff
at the movie was was kind of silly I
don't think he came into the role trying
to half-ass it at all but he just
doesn't hit the right marks for
Daredevil for me plus his chemistry with
elektres
weirdly flat how did these two end up
together in real life they're so awkward
in this movie I just don't really buy
this romance an elektra's whole thing
where she's the girl next door daughter
of a billionaire but also just happens
to be a ninja it just feels weird
this is a terrible way to introduce her
Colin Farrell is on a different planet
from everyone else in this movie this
Bullseye feels like he's played by two
actors Colin Farrell and crack
oh
yeah
he's such a cartoon character and it
feels like he was told to be as over the
top as possible in a way that's
hilarious in like an ironic
unintentional way like I just can't take
him seriously he's completely out of his
mind I watched this movie with my friend
William in this single frame of Bullseye
is so funny that it killed him right
there he's never been the same can
anyone put this as a custom head for a
Marvel Legends figure that'd be so
funny this movie has a really
weird obsession with naming extras and
Side characters after comic book writers
and artists and it comes across more
inappropriate than fun if I was joking
Sada I'd be pissed they named a rapist
after him she asked me if I want to
stick around
for some fun it does lead to some good
out of context clips though
as you're sick I hope Justice is found
here today
for justice finds you jack Murdoch has
to fight John romita hey you son of a
I'm gonna make you look like I'm
my son draws a character with bruises
one of the major drawbacks for me is
that I feel like the film is lacking
anything stylistically that it can call
its own not much really stands out to
the point where I can go oh hey that
reminds me of that Daredevil 2003 movie
the direction just seems to be biting
off the stylization of other superhero
movies that were recent at the time it's
got suit up scenes right out of
Schumacher's Batman and it feels like
it's lightly stealing iconography from
Remy Spiderman they're not really doing
much that's identifiable and unique to
itself I guess the only exception to
this is probably the radar Vision scenes
a lot of people said morbius kind of
look like this it's the first and really
only time a live action property has
attempted to show us what it's like
inside Daredevil's head the TV show
would only do like one single shot in
its entire run though I do wonder why is
it blue Ben fix that editing yeah look
at that that's more like it I really
can't see why they went with blue over
red for any reason other than it's more
scary and less Whimsical but that's part
of the point what do you
actually see
the world's on fire nobody's doing it
like Spider-Man Tas even Daredevil was
on point there otherwise the action is
at the very least serviceable for a
daredevil thing Daredevil's always kind
of stretching the bounds of what's
possible for a normal human being in
combat but we accept it and enjoy it
because he's dressed in a devil costume
actually you know what would have helped
hide the CGI stunt doubles better around
this time period full body costumes
seems like a missed opportunity since
you already have one guy in a crazy
outfit between this and the Ghost Rider
movies the first one even being from the
same director I've noticed a pattern
from this time period where superhero
movies felt like they could only really
stomach having one character in a comic
accurate costume at a time and the rest
had to be in street clothes or human
forms Spider-Man being the exception of
course because they were completely
unashamed to have a silly cackling man
in a Goblin suit flying around blowing
people up
why do we not learn better lessons from
Spider-Man's success for like another 10
years for all the Vibes it took from
Spider-Man they seem to miss a lot of
the other important Hallmarks that made
that so memorable and cool bullseye's
wardrobe instead consists of just a blue
jacket that makes a rattlesnake noise
for some reason
and for the love of God kids don't make
your superhero uniform out of leather
you'll get heat stroke and it doesn't
stretch well for your flying roundhouse
kicks Toby Maguire's suit looked like
robber in some shots but at its core
it's just foam muscle padding covered by
plain old spandex they just painted it
up real good
feel like I didn't appreciate those
movies enough as a kid I can't imagine
where we'd be without them and again
those movies wouldn't exist without
Spider-Man Tas I know a lot of people
insist that the director's cut of
Daredevil is better but I feel like it's
just
longer I think a lot of this makes
perfect sense to have cut having Ben
yurik just walk up to Matt and announce
that he's going to out his secret
identity in an article was unnecessary
the ending flows better with him just
coming to his own decision to kill the
story and preserve a secret the added
subplot of the additional lawyer stuff
is nice only because it gives Matt and
foggy more time to riff and be buddies
but the actual courtroom scenes aren't
that compelling and it adds even more to
the pile of scenes where Daredevil is
just absolutely terrible with keeping
his secret identity a secret of which
there are just so many to choose from he
basically tells Elektra how his powers
work on their first date with the
raindrops highlighting her face his
baton he left at a crime scene is also
his walking stick yeah that too hey why
are you in there what about the scene
with Iron Man effortless
cuffed to the car he's been blind since
he was a kid he doesn't know how to use
a gear shift then he goes why hasn't
your goddamn heart rate changed
having a Kung Fu battle with Elektra in
broad daylight in front of all these
Witnesses constantly telegraphing the
foggy that he can recognize when an
attractive woman has entered the room
literally dunking on foggy maybe that
last one was just because he was a
really good lawyer the other biggest
struggle with the movie is just not
really knowing how to write any good
drama the impetus of Matt's entire moral
Arc in the movie is this frightened
child that was a random bystander for
him savagely beating up a criminal and
without any subtlety he just starts
chanting I'm not the bad guy kid not the
bad guy
I'm not the bad guy
this whole scene could have worked if he
just took out the clunky dialogue and
then like the really silly scene of him
brooding on a rooftop and just saying
what he's feeling have him like notice
the kid then wordlessly back off from
the guy and sneak away and then smash
cut to him stashing the costume back at
his apartment like damn that got out of
hand
something a little bit more show don't
tell you know or even better yet you
could have Matt Murdoch scare himself by
beating on a guy too much and having a
crisis over whether he's trying to
enforce Street Justice or he's just
enjoying the catharsis of violence to
get over how many problems he's had in
life and he'll wonder if he's going to
have to take a life to stop the city
from devolving into further chaos oh
yeah he also like barely says anything
in the church scenes to the point that
I'm like not even sure why they're there
this conflict is handled in such an
obvious and Bland way that the payoff of
sparing Wilson Fisk at the end doesn't
have nearly enough weight to it every
emotional beat with Elektra is ruined by
playing an Evanescence song and an
example of one of the most inappropriate
needle drops in a superhero adaptation
until sweatpants and moon girl and devil
dinosaur
my daycare when I'm born rich life ain't
fair I really wish to God they hadn't
thrown these in here because now these
songs just make me laugh every time I
hear them this time
Elektra thinking Daredevil was the one
who killed her father was contrived
because just resolved way too quickly
and it feels like it only serves as an
excuse for a pointless extra fight scene
between them and lastly Matt and Kingpin
have like nothing to do with each other
and it sucks Daredevil barely knows
Kingpin exists throughout the majority
of the movie
you can't kingpin's got to be footing
the bill
and when his connections to him become
apparent it's way too late in the movie
so we don't get to build any kind of
rivalry they share two scenes together
he doesn't learn Wilson Fisk his Kingpin
until Bullseye just flat out tells him
like an idiot and then Daredevil's like
oh yeah I saw that guy at a party one
time finding out Fisk was the one who
killed his dad happens at the very last
minute as an attempt to give the
character more of a dramatic reason for
their fight other than opposing
ideologies
but it doesn't really feel like it
matters or changes much they were trying
to do like uh I'm gonna kill MJ
Spider-Man moment where he's like oh hey
I'm motivated to kick your ass now oh
you know what it's like trying to do the
moment where you find out Joker shot
Batman's parents in the 89 movie but
they don't emphasize it nearly as much
and in that one Batman and Joker spent a
lot of time butting heads prior to that
reveal I also don't really think it was
necessary if they were going to barely
do anything with it anyone could have
killed Jack Murdoch and it still would
have had the same effect on Daredevil's
Life in the movie thus far it didn't
have to also conveniently be the main
bad guy the TV show didn't do that and
it did a much better job of developing
the hatred between these two guys who
had never met before season one on the
other hand the Spider-Man episode had it
so Matt Murdoch was fully aware for
years that young Wilson Fisk killed his
dad and spent ages building a case
publicly and privately to take the
Kingpin down
one or the other this Middle Road thing
offers no real reason to get invested
I'm sure this is some sacred childhood
movie to someone out there but I promise
you I'm the same age I grew up with it
too it's not really that good champ
and if you think I'm an for
saying it's bad and criticizing it then
you have to say the same to Ben Affleck
this movie's messy packed to the gills
with way too much going on all at once
and not sure what tone it wants to go
for it doesn't have that camp and
earnestness of Spider-Man it doesn't
have the staunch reality of X-Men and it
doesn't have the deliberate crushing
sadness of the Hulk it's trying to do
all of that at once and can't succeed
with any of them the director's cut is
two hours long and it spends a lot of
time dragging ass on stuff that they
were right to cut for the standard
version
it's not egregiously bad like some
superhero stuff from around this time
but I see why this one isn't fondly
remembered even the people who worked on
it didn't have nice things to say about
it though the Silver Linings that all of
these actors later got to be in much
better comic book movies well except
Michael Clark Duncan he was in Green
Lantern oh and Jennifer Garner
you know I was actually wondering why
I've never heard anyone talk about this
movie before online I wasn't expecting
it to be some kind of Hidden Gem but I
was expecting there to be something to
make it worth bringing up in
conversation but I get it now this movie
isn't hilariously bad but it's also not
good it's just boring it's so slow and
Bland it's just a big old nothing
sandwich of a movie I just finished it a
few minutes ago as of writing this
script and I
I feel like I'm already forgetting what
happened in it it's noteworthy in the
lineage of Marvel movies because this
and Daredevil are the first ever
examples of two unrelated Marvel
projects sharing continuity this is the
first Marvel Cinematic Universe
that's depressing so even though stick
and the chaste and the hand and all that
Frank Miller Jazz was left out of
Daredevil it's present here and that
bothers me to no end stick just never
met Daredevil and
Matt Murdock trained himself to fight by
jumping on rooftops all day long
whatever instead of just learning even
more martial arts Elektra also learns
how to have Final Destination
premonitions of her own death and how to
revive people from the dead like they
did to her
but Elektra is too much of a rebel and
leaves the chase to go be an assassin
For Hire instead of just being like a
doctor and cashing in on that Miyagi
magic technique she's got the plot
starts to actually happen when she's
hired demoita the guy who wrote the
ultimates and his daughter who has some
secret for why the hand wants to take
her out with just a short amount of time
Elektra bonds with the young girl with
the map to dry land tattooed on her back
that's immune to the cordyceps virus and
also the son of Mephisto who will one
day lead the future resistance Against
the Machines then she decides to not
kill them and instead will protect them
from a gaggle of boring assassins
working for
Shang Tsung
they even have the same magic tattoos as
Mortal Kombat Annihilation apparently
members of the hand turn into Green
Smoke and disappear when they die
because they'd run out of internal
memory rendering all the ragdolls so
they need to despawn also this character
is supposed to be Typhoid Mary from the
comics I guess she's an evil slag and
deserves to get thrown out a window like
80 more times for what she did to
Deadpool she's also an iron fist season
2 which nobody watched get her Electra
foreign
laughs
what the I'd buy that scytherow if
Spider-Man did it but just about any
other character in the Marvel Universe
and I'm calling I would raise
an eyebrow if even Bullseye made that
throw if I seem a little bit all over
the place with this one it's because I'm
trying my absolute damnedest to figure
out what to even say about this movie
it's like watching paint dry I guess if
there's anything I can commend it for
it's that it subverted the usual special
child Trope by having twist be that Abby
is actually an ultra martial arts super
Prodigy that can kick ass too the hand
wants her just because with a little bit
of Mind Control she could be their best
assassin ever I also like finding out
that stick was the one who hired Elektra
to go after these two in the first place
because he knew she was a good person
deep down and would end up protecting
them instead there's some neat moments
in here character-wise it's just that
they're all compacted into relatively
the same five-minute window while the
entire movie preceding it and after it
are very dull there's also nothing about
the action that's really unique or
memorable or really even that cool I
think Elektra ran on a tree that a guy
cut down with his superpowers and then
the tree just fell on him but I don't
know why she was running on it because
she wasn't really influencing the
direction of the tree so he just made a
mistake and squished himself and she was
like trying to make it look like it was
her idea thank God for the Netflix show
once again doing a more comic accurate
Elektra and stick I may not have totally
loved Daredevil season 2 because of its
weird pacing and distracting from
Punisher but after seeing this I have
more appreciation for what they did with
the characters and all the lore with the
hand and Elektra herself
the Jennifer Garner Elektra feels like a
movie made on autopilot by a ton of
people who didn't know or care that much
about the source material just like
making a movie for the sake of it
however if this movie was starring a
bumbling male sitcom actor in the lead
had more note not better Just more
special effects a cameo from Wong and
black widow and you know what throwing a
giant blue laser in the sky in the last
fight scene and I think people would say
that's one of the best Marvel movies yet
I always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only one dollar Isn't that
cool if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator quote Xavier GM next
time you buy a silly dancer cool
character skin really helps me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign